Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: eric vautier
[Le sous-titre est un compromis volontaire
entre la voix off et la langue des signes]
Bonjour à tous.
Je m'appelle Henri, Henri Corderoy.
Je suis né sourd.
Je peux parler mais pas assez bien
pour que vous puissiez comprendre,
c'est pour ça que je fais intervenir
une interprète
qui peut vous faire comprendre
ce que je dis en langue des signes
Saint-Exupéry aurait tout à fait pu
être sourd,
parce qu'à l'époque il y avait
énormément de bruit dans les avions.
Et il n'y avait pas de radio.
Il y a également un autre pilote
qui s'appelle Lindbergh,
qui a traversé l'Océan Atlantique
de New York jusqu'à Paris
pendant 33 heures et cela sans radio.
Et c'était en 1927.
10% de la population française
ont des problèmes d'audition.
Alors vous allez me dire,
qu'est-ce que ça fait si on n'entend pas ?
Est-ce que vraiment on peut piloter ?
Est-ce que vous, par exemple,
vous seriez monté avec Saint-Exupéry
s'il avait été sourd ?
je vais avoir 58 ans après demain.
J'ai passé les deux tiers
de ma vie à voler.
Souvent les personnes m'ont dit :
« Tu n'en es pas capable,
c'est pas possible que tu pilotes ! »
Pourtant, j'ai été le premier élève
de l'école nationale de l'aviation
civile de Toulouse en 1982.
Et à ce moment-là,
j'étais au courant qu'en Amérique
de nombreux pilotes sourds existaient.
En France, c'était très très compliqué
pour obtenir une licence.
Peu importe, je suis parti en Amérique
et j'ai obtenu ma licence
en cinq semaines.
Je suis devenu pilote d'avion.
C'était en 1990.
Suite à ça, j'ai refait le même
coup de poker en Angleterre en 2004.
J'ai également vécu une superbe aventure
en volant en Australie.
C'est vrai qu'il est très difficile
d'obtenir une dérogation médicale
pour devenir pilote privé.
Dès qu'on a un handicap auditif,
les médecins en général refusent
de nous donner cet accès-là.
Vous allez me dire :
« Mais comment est-ce possible ?
Est-ce que vous n'êtes pas un peu fou
de voler alors que vous êtes sourd ? »
Souvent les personnes se disent :
« Non, un pilote sourd, c'est pas possible
parce qu'il ne peut pas
utiliser la radio. »
Mais la radio, c'est pas obligé.
Bien sûr c'est obligé
si on veut être pilote de ligne,
pilote de transport,
pilote dans l'armée, etc.
Mais en France, il y a environ
deux tiers des aérodromes
qui sont dépourvus de tour de contrôle.
C'est-à-dire qu'il n'y a pas la radio.
L'une des normes principales
de l'aviation, c'est d'être vu.
Un pilote se doit de voir et d'éviter.
Pour la sécurité de tous les pilotes,
il faut être vu et voir.
Par exemple, être vu et voir
quand on atterrit, quand on décolle,
et pour éviter toute collision.
Et ça, un sourd en est
tout à fait capable.
Il y a des moyens qui sont mis en œuvre,
par exemple les GPS, les transpondeurs,
qui permettent
une communication sans radio.
Mais il y a également
des moyens de communication visuels
et via des flashs
comme vous pouvez le voir derrière.
C'est via la tour de contrôle
qui envoie ces flashs-là
aux avions qui sont dans l'espace aérien.
Et par exemple, c'est très utilisé
pour des exercices de panne radio.
Mercredi dernier, j'étais près de Paris,
j'ai effectué un vol
et j'ai utilisé ce système-là
sans problème.
Le monde de l'aviation, ça me fait penser,
dans les années 50,
pour les personnes sourdes
qui souhaitaient conduire.
A cette époque-là,
les personnes disaient :
« Non, non ! Une personne sourde,
elle peut pas conduire,
c'est interdit, c'est pas possible ! »
Regardez maintenant :
les personnes sourdes conduisent,
c'est un fait tout à fait banal.
Alors j'espère qu'il aura
la même évolution pour les avions.
Mais c'est vrai
que c'est très très difficile
de convaincre le conseil médical,
qui malheureusement ne donne
qu'au compte-gouttes les autorisations
pour que les personnes sourdes
puissent voler.
Ces réticences qu'ont le conseil médical,
aux États-Unis, elles n'existent pas.
Aux États-Unis, il y a plus de 250 sourds
qui ont la licence de pilote.
Ils ont cette licence de PPL,
d'avions privés.
Et il va y en avoir de plus en plus.
Il y a des Américains,
il y a un Australien, un Hongrois,
un Français que je connais,
et également dans d'autres pays,
par exemple en Australie, il y environ
une dizaine de pilotes sourds ;
en Angleterre, il y en a une quinzaine,
il y en aura bientôt au Brésil
et bien sûr, j'espère qu'il y en aura
plusieurs en France.
Alors il y a des solutions innovantes.
Je participe d'ailleurs un nouveau projet
qui s'appelle Fans For All,
comme vous pouvez le voir.
Ce projet permet de donner des solutions
aux communications par radio.
C'est un projet qui permet de développer
un nouvel équipement pour les avions
permettant la communication
bidirectionnelle
entre la tour de contrôle et les avions.
C'est un système qui fonctionne
au moyen de signaux textuels
et d'indicateurs lumineux.
C'est un moyen qui est fait
à partir de normes existantes
qui sont développées et déjà réalisées
depuis les années 80
pour un système qui s'appelle CPDLC,
qui est utilisé d'ailleurs
dans les avions de ligne.
C'est en évolution et ça va être
adapté aux plus petits avions.
Alors évidemment, les personnes sourdes
vont en bénéficier
mais en fait tous les pilotes
pourront en bénéficier.
Pour atterrir, pour décoller,
pour permettre un contrôle plus précis.
Alors évidemment,
il faut accélérer le développement.
Comme je vous le disais,
les sourds en bénéficieront
mais également les entendants.
C'est un nouvel outil de communication
plus sûr et plus fiable
pour tous les avions,
et pour tout l'espace aérien
qui devient malheureusement
de plus en plus saturé.
C'est vraiment une solution intéressante
également pour les pilotes
qui ont des problèmes d'élocution.
il y a également l'ULM, c'est vrai
que ça donne une véritable liberté
parce qu'il y a beaucoup moins
de contraintes.
C'est pour ça qu'il y a environ
une quarantaine de sourds
qui utilisent l'ULM.
Mes combats et ma persévérance
m'ont permis d'obtenir enfin
ma licence en 2007 en France.
J'ai maintenant plus de 2 300 heures
de vol en avion et en ULM.
Alors, voler, c'est incroyable,
c'est un sentiment de liberté,
ça enlève toutes les inquiétudes
du quotidien,
des problèmes sociaux
ou du travail personnel.
J'aime énormément, c'est ma passion
et c'est pour ça qu'avec les personnes
qui m'encouragent,
qui me soutiennent, je discute
énormément avec eux,
c'est un vrai partage.
En parlant de partage,
je suis instructeur également d'ULM
pour des élèves sourds et malentendants
à l'aérodrome de Coulommiers
à côté de Paris.
La France, c'est un beau pays
et je pense que la France
peut nous aider à réaliser nos rêves.
La frustration, c'est un sentiment
qui n'est pas agréable.
et pourtant beaucoup de sourds
et de malentendants le ressentent.
Mais c'est aussi une force, ça nous permet
de repousser les limites
que nous donne la législation,
ces normes qui ne devraient pas être.
Alors il faut se battre
pour dépasser les épreuves.
En bon Gascon que je suis,
je dis souvent
« Un pour tous et tous pour un ».
La vie m'a aussi appris
« Aide-toi et le ciel t'aidera ».
Mais s'il y a un message
que je veux vous transmettre
à vous tous aujourd'hui,
cela vient d'un ami à moi
qui est également pilote,
Gérard Feldzer, ici présent,
qui dit : « Si tu peux, vas-y ! »
Merci d'avoir écouté.
(Applaudissements)